whoo I don't want him to watch this I'm
fine with that
I would rather at least for me a family
who comes before all else I think that I
am a lot more like my family like then I
care to admit
and so I feel like if they're not
getting good readings on my partner
I'm probably overlooking something I
would rather date someone than my family
adores and that my friends despise no
that's that's nuts
if my parents hate my partner that's not
that bad and also I disappoint them
probably already so it's fine I would
rather that my parents hate my partner
[Music]
Pass
I would rather discover that my partner
is married and has kids if they have a
kid with someone else it's a lot more
emotionally involved
I would rather find out that they have a
family and kids because of them I would
feel a little bit less guilty when I
take them out of my house right I don't
know that to me feels like the answer I
don't know yeah it would suck more to to
find out now that my girlfriend is
pregnant with another person's child
that would be way worse if my girlfriend
had children already oh but she's still
married but that's fine because that
means that life in her mind is over I'm
the new goodness and when there are
terrible children I can leave I mean
depends one-two-three son was up first
before I was dating I would really care
that much wow is eating
they're both cheating that's messed up
probably cheated on me with an ex of
theirs I'd rather that my partner had a
threesome grab me it's like a 50/50
right
okay so first of all that's a very hard
question to answer so we're gonna ignore
that someone that's terrible in that
you'll figure it out hopefully and if
not and it's still sex yeah absolutely
the second one also you can kiss
anywhere really
sex well it could happen anywhere for me
it only happens in day I don't want to
do it in the park
I would rather date someone who is
terrible and go but a fantastic kisser
I would do literally being sewn together
fresher I've done long-distance before
and it's terrible okay if if I have to
choose between the two and I'm being
totally honest with myself it would be a
long distance because being sewn to
another person sounds awful
[Music]